los sacos está nicolás ajos y desde el
señor ratzinger era hasta valérie
pécresse
y ya está el señor david ver como ese no
es nuestro presidente mañana a
continuación
aunque haya un nuevo cambio de gobierno
no les dejaría escapar y estarán ahí
fotografiados que darán a luz y dice que
le deje los harkis no te olvides de los
harkis eso es todo si tu hija y hermana
dejar keys asesinados ahí ya vives cerca
de él y lo lleva luchando desde los 18
años para que el estado francés
reconozca plenamente a todos los
argelinos que sirvieron el ejército
francés durante la guerra de argelia al
lado de su sobrino recuerda aquella
noche mortal de junio de 1959 tenía seis
años su padre y sus tres hermanos
estaban en casa de permiso
sucedió entre la medianoche y la una de
la madrugada vinieron a llamar a la
puerta
mi padre fue abrir la puerta el portón y
le dijeron la familia está la de volver
al cuarto irak quienes serán de militar
hoy dijeron que eran soldados franceses
pero no eran soldados franceses eran
miembros del fmln disfrazados de
soldados franceses dólar
y en francés josé
cansando repleta de 15 días después
encontraron los cuerpos descompuestos en
sus uniformes militares militar
militar
las cabezas puestas a un lado corte en
el miembro en la boca del bus
eso se lo dije al señor macro
para mí fueron cuatro personas que se
fueron por esta bandera azul blanca y
roja
estoy orgulloso de esta historia y me
siento totalmente francés como mi tía y
solo tengo 19 años no soy responsable de
los desórdenes del mundo son guerras es
así pero no veo porque debo negar mi
historia no es mi historia y estoy
orgulloso de ella encajo pero también
necesitamos que nos muestren la prueba
de que somos amados eso es claramente
que somos amados
60 años después de los acuerdos de avión
los horrores perpetrados por argelinos y
franceses durante la guerra siguen
siendo en gran medida un tabú en ambos
países en la numerosa familia de aisa
ismael es el único que quiere seguir
rompiendo el silencio seguimos luchando
no importa que político esté a la cabeza
del estado necesitamos un reconocimiento
financiero y que en las escuelas
personas que realmente vivieron esta
historia acompañadas por supuesto de
historiadores cuenten la historia a los
jóvenes
durante el conflicto el ejército francés
reclutó hasta 200.000 harkis como
auxiliares